well with german germany struggling to
contain a massive surge in covert 19
infections talk of a vaccine mandate is
heating up in the coming weeks the new
parliament will vote on whether to
require all residents to get the jab in
the meantime germany's federal and state
leaders have decreed that care home
workers must get vaccinated but there
are concerns that the measure could lead
to serious staffing shortages if they
react by quitting their jobs
matthias postman has been working as a
geriatric nurse for 12 years
he supports the decision to introduce
mandatory vaccination for care workers
to keep the risk of infection as low as
possible for everyone here
you feel safer knowing for certain that
all of your colleagues all the people
you work with are vaccinated
and that there are no ifs and butts on
that front
vaccine hesitancy or even refusal has
proven a pervasive problem in germany's
care home sector
how pervasive no one knows that's why
andrea yeager welcomes the mandates but
she says they shouldn't be limited to
nurses
i would like to see the government move
more swiftly to introduce a general
nationwide vaccine requirement instead
of just focusing on the sectors that are
already under pressure
i don't like the message the sends or
the pressure this puts on nurses you
must get vaccinated while essentially
telling everyone else that they can take
their sweet time because they're not as
likely to drive up infections
a national mandate is under debate but
it wouldn't go into effect until
february in the meantime to protect the
particularly vulnerable the government
is now eyeing a targeted mandate for all
nursing home staff a move welcomed by
many in the business
you can't just single out any one group
or industry because there's no way of
knowing if they're the ones responsible
there are so many people involved in
running a nursing home from housekeeping
to the janitor from care attendance to
those who work in administration and
often enter patients rooms
[Music]
but some worry that the mix of covered
19 staff shortages and vaccine
requirements are placing too big a
burden on workers already stretched to
their limits
those who are still left to shoulder
this undue burden are being put under
even more pressure and i worry that this
could be the last straw that they'll go
i can't i won't do this anymore and quit
for nurse matthias busman though vaccine
mandates are the only way to get out of
this crisis first for care homes and
hospitals then for the rest of the
country
i say vaccinate anyone and everyone as
fast as humanly possible
[Music]
let's talk now to andrew allman he's a
member of the german parliament for the
fdp and a doctor with expertise in
infectious diseases dr ulman how
concerned are you that the mandatory
vaccination will cause people in the
nursing field to quit their jobs
honestly i'm not too concerned if we
look into other countries in europe like
for example france or
united kingdom we do see some people
leaving their job but on the other hand
most of the people stay there and stay
put and it's obvious that we have an
issue there however i think it's very
important and shows some kind of
responsibility
if we get the vaccine mandate out there
in the institutions and again it's not
the nursing staff per se it's all the
staff who are working in an institution
now the buddhist target is set to debate
a vote on a nationwide vaccination
mandate how sure are you that there will
be a majority for it in parliament
well the first step we're starting this
week in parliament is mandatory
vaccination institution for institutions
like hospitals or nursing care or a
private practice
that has to be first implemented and the
next steps are being debated right now
internally how far we will go with the
mandate of vaccination for the whole
population or special groups in our
population for example the elderly or
the adults
your party the fdp has for a long time
promised that there'll be no mandatory
vaccination nationwide
many people who voted for you now say
they feel betrayed others are worried
that the divisions in society will get
even deeper what do you say to them
well the truth is all parties
said they do not want to have vaccine
mandates or mandatory vaccination i said
the same thing by the way even during
the campaigning i said
mandatory vaccination is not the route
that we have to follow we have to
convince the people we have to
make it understandable why vaccinations
are important however the situation is
getting worse we are understanding how
long a vaccination
is helpful probably just only for six
months we need the booster
vaccination
we we have the israeli data that shows
very clearly how important this third
job is and we have to get the vaccine
into the people right now and the
responsibility is very clear our health
care system is on the edge especially in
certain areas like saxony or or in
bavaria and that's where we have to show
responsibility and we cannot keep our
promises for a situation that got worse
now a member of the ethics council is
advising against compulsory vaccination
and has asked whether the government has
done enough to promote voluntary
vaccination
in your opinion has the government done
enough
no clearly the government didn't do
enough otherwise we would be in a
totally different situation today
again the third
vaccination the third [ __ ] it wasn't put
into place or was recommended
early enough despite the fact that
israel was doing that already and was
getting out of the way that they were
experiencing and now the new government
will probably be put in place this week
in our parliament and i'm pretty sure
that we are going to do this differently
and hopefully better so that we can in
front of the wave and not walking behind
the wave that's the only way that we can
get out of this crisis
all right dr andrew allman doctor and
member of the german parliament for the
fdp thanks very much for your time
thank you as well